the mandalorian season two finale
airs tomorrow tomorrow
is to tomorrow with that in mind
we're gonna watch from star wars theory
palpatine took
grogu or as we like to call him yoda2
yoda also during order 66.
fun opening huh hey fun openings i bet
they're gonna hold off till
season three they're gonna tease us with
something on giving us the answer of
who to grow goo away from order 66. i
bet they're gonna hold off on that
you disney bastards
such tease as you are no no it's
such
oh very good very good that's a good
yoda you're a good coach
during the mandalorian season 2 episode
5 ahsoka mentions that grogu's memory
grows dark and
faint after he was hidden at the end of
the clone wars aka
order 66 he was raised at the jedi
temple on coruscant
many masters trained him over the years
at the end of the clone wars he was
hidden someone took him from the temple
then his memory becomes dark now before
we begin
say well some jedi took him and
mind-wiped him to keep him
safe so he didn't know how to use the
forces some jedi
[Music]
theory and you can decide if it makes
sense or not at the end
so my next theory here after the anakin
one i did
recently is that perhaps sidious took
him this wouldn't make sense
since sidious was at the jedi temple
after anakin raided it with the final
first you might be confused
well a lot of people missed this detail
but we can actually see sidious in the
jedi temple as anakin kneels before him
calling him his master obi-wan is
watching the security recordings from
the temple when this happens
this was in palpatine's office which is
not in the temple
then it wouldn't make sense for kenobi
to be able to see welcome to my office
my secretary will let you in could have
taken grogu as anakin will leave and
sidious will be in the temple without
him
you'll see and mind you this is starting
when obi-wan is witnessing anakin
killing the jedi
during the hologram and i should mention
also that the book is a lot more
descriptive
of the things anakin does do the jedi
with the fiber first
then the caped man turned to meet a
cloaked fighter behind him like what
what
i wished he had the strength to rip his
eyes out of his head but even blind
he would see this forever he would see
his friend his student
his brother turn and kneel in front of a
black crooked lord of the sith
his head rang with a silent scream
that's powerful
destroyed the well-written steering
christensen impressions
you have done well my new apprentice
do you feel your power growing yes
you feel that power growing everyday
your skills are
unmatched by any shift before you
go forth my boy go forth and bring
peace to our empire
what is this baby
this is right before anakin goes to stop
by padme's place
before blasting off to move to far to
officially end the clone wars by having
newt gun ray deactivate
all the droids across the galaxy so when
anakin is here with padme
sidious is at the temple and it's this
time gap
that i'm thinking where we never see
that allow cities to search for any
hiding jedi who survived
palpatine perhaps senses grogu now how
does he know about grogu
well my answer is dooku was a jedi
master who left the temple
after decades of being there since he
was a small boy
and who is old enough to know dooku
possibly to even be trained by him
trained by him man
and in the revenge of the sith novel the
plan was for dooku and anakin to be
alive
and serve him so which of course we know
what happened there
poor guy i believe dooku would have told
cities all about grogu
and how he was immensely powerful just
like his father
yoda if that is his father at all and
i'm just saying that today it's
more dramatic you're probably we're all
probably right
his child would be sweeter than killing
him imagine turning into a
dude or harvesting what a painful
revenge
[Music]
resurrection remember he needed a being
with very high midichlorians in their
blood
a high m count anakin shades some of his
power off once he lost to ob1
and this is what george lucas has always
said that darth vader only became 80
percent as powerful as the emperor once
he lost on mustafar
is around the same age as anakin so he
would have been about 20 years old
during revenge of the sith
and his forced powers were far more
powerful than what we see in the
mandalorian
he had to subdue his powers as to not be
found by the empire
now whether he subdued them himself or
someone
turned his memory dark so that he
wouldn't remember how to use his powers
i don't know i guess we'll find out so
what i'm thinking is he was
how did he get out how did he get away
and maybe sent to camino to be an
experiment
and to learn from and there during the
next 35 or so
years until we see him in the mando he
perhaps escaped
and then came under the custody of the
remnants of the empire now
sidious's clone in episode 9 looks to be
about 30 years old here
rey was born in 15 aby that's five years
after the mandalorian just about so this
would mean if he was put on jakku
around the age of maybe six meaning 21
aby then palpatine's clone's son rey's
dad was born about 10 years after
revenge of the sith
okay following sidious was trying to
clone himself
for quite some time and trying to
experiment with different ways to put
the force inside a new body
this could give life to my theory that
palpatine did indeed take grogu from the
temple the only other option is that he
traveled with a jedi who survived and
escaped
maybe like sir junda from fallen order
and the inquisitors intercepted her
took the child and put him in possession
of the empire personally i like the
palpatine theory
if he did take him he just run tests on
him as much as he could
perhaps keeping grogu alive so that his
body
will potentially harvest his blood as it
grew perhaps this is why they didn't
just kill him off
they needed more of his blood and they
knew his blood had the perfect high
m count but there just wasn't enough of
it for more trials
so they need him to get bigger they
tried with other things as much as they
could
i'm thinking but they ultimately knew
that if they killed the child
they wouldn't find any other entity with
as high of a force power in their blood
this is why
he couldn't just take any random jedi
and use them this actually could be all
plausible
you know whatever i think i'm actually
good sounds like his discovery he's
going off strip now
check like this damn it
what believe in yourself
just let him go free in the galaxy until
he was found again or did a jedi do that
what were they protecting
information or information
so did palpatine take groku to train him
or to drain his blood for his
experiments in his search for
immortality his master
darth plagueis always said essence
transfer was super lame
he said it wasn't true immortality it
was the worst star wars book the worst
dialogue
super lamb don't even try
remember my fellow giant sith friends
the force will be with you
always you know it
would be really cool if
uh palpatine did take him
i i i it would be a problem a pretty
heavy heartbreaking reveal and it would
have a lot of sinister
i think it would tie in very well
especially with that episode
where they do discover the clones for
the first time episode the carl weathers
directed episode
yeah where they have like the laboratory
yeah yeah
so it would work and uh i think it would
tie in
nicely especially since a lot of the
theories started emerging
that oh my god this is looks like it's
going to be tying into the disney sequel
trilogy
with palpatine finding out that he was
clone and how we got there looked like
snoke
yada yada yada so in some ways i
actually really do love the idea of
palpatine
discovering him but my mind is telling
me that
how palpatine really found him was
palpatine went to go take a [ __ ] uh-huh
yup
definitely and he opened the door and he
was like is anyone in here
no finally some privacy
then he he went to poop and then when he
sat down whipped out
the uh wikipedia yeah
wookie roddick vodka magazine magazine
and he was just reading it and then he
heard something
and then he looked down and then uh
there was there was little yoda
going to who he thought was chancellor
palpatine in the bathroom all the the
best places to come up with confront
somebody master
master anakin is murdering us
oh what the hell are you i'm trying to
get some quiet time
couldn't you wait they're stuck together
because of how awkward of a situation
that was
i'm just trying to earn a collab with
star wars theory no yeah
yeah we can come up with a good enough
theory right here right now
to get on that channel and pitch it
right is more
realistic yeah if you got caught in a
compromising position you know you're
you're a chancellor you're also a dark
lord like
you don't want to be embarrassed like
that and have your leadership
undermine just saying by human biology
you know i just want everyone to know
this type of
lowbrow comedy commentary is not an
accurate representation of how we cover
the mandalorian this poop joke is not
canon
to the rest of our comments no just let
me get that clear all the people who
watched
episodes one through seven were like i
don't think i'm gonna watch that finale
with them
it's not gonna be a question though i
mean i really like the theory it all
makes sense it all lines up
and i actually prefer that over the
anakin one it just feels a lot more
sinister and a lot more
why he might be more frightened and
fearful i mean yeah i think it'd have
the same effect if it was
freaking anakin skywalker but palpatine
is much more of a menacing presence in
my opinion anakin was still anakin he
wasn't
the fully formed darth vader according
to the theory of
if he did take grogu whereas palpatine i
mean just look at him yeah
he didn't have powers he'd be able to
get away from me yeah that seems well
within his long game and then yeah like
the idea that he would then harvest
these young langs grogo being among them
take them to some facility
and then you know there's still an
element of mystery there as to how grogu
could have gotten out of that facility
but you know if you think again
about what we've seen across other
installments both in the mandalorian and
in the sequels but certainly go to
expand on the theory of these
experiments in you know harvesting and
transferring mini chlorines and whatnot
it's fun because it leaves you more room
to speculate as to how he escaped
you know from that scenario i just
there's i love all the theories i've
been hearing and they all sound
plausible
i gotta point something out though of
why i have a hard time sometimes
believing these theories
and and i mean this sincerely
okay you know what you never see grogu
do
what's that i'll show you
all you see this guy did
yeah he like crawls it's clear that his
size is
inhibiting like i'm saying
that you have these thoughts about him
escaping getting away
like this this guy never moves so
what makes me fascinated is you know
he's 50 years old
they're talking about all the training
he had and how he had to repress
the force and all that we don't know
much about this little guy's race
do you guys when he repressed the force
did it also like
make him a baby again yeah yeah yeah i
guess she was like is in repressing his
forcibility like would it be that in the
past when he was 20 years old or
whatever on this theory's timeline would
he have been flipping around
and jumping and stuff like we've seen
yeah yoda too
at certain points or would yeah he'd be
a baby
that's why when i was watching this
video i had one note
you guys can't see who it says still
a baby baby that's all it says
and it seems like 50 is a pretty young
age for this
species race like i get it if you're
like oh no they ate slowly
when this in this species races but
they're talking about how
oh but no he was on coruscant and he was
you know becoming a jedi it was a
paddleboard
and he and i'm like oh we need him and
the man
but that doesn't yeah necessarily mean
they have adult physiological ability
to benjamin but in myself in order to
really hide from the dark side
you know yeah i feel like if he was
broken out of a
testing facility somebody else would
have been responsible
it's more likely someone took him away
than it is
i feel like in all scenarios someone
else is moving him regardless i think
in terms of the one i'd want to see is
calcastus that's the one i'd want to see
at least to talk about meeting the jedi
uh
after ahsoka gives directions you know
pulls up her google maps and all that
is after ahsoka gives directions meeting
that jedi would like that to be calcus's
whereas uh in terms of who took grogu
from order 66
i think it would be interesting to bring
palpatine the show probably my favorite
one
to go down either way whatever the show
does i'm usually like
because it's a twist to be sinister you
know it's a twist to be
sinister well mandalorian season two
finale
comes out tomorrow you best bet we'll be
stressing about making sure to get it
out
saturday morning because everyone else
gets letters up on
friday but we're like let them do their
thing
let's make it more challenging for hours
to get so okay yeah let's go that
mentality subscribe click that
notification bell hit the like button
thank you star wars theory i love your
channel you
kill it man please let us go on there
pitch more bathroom ideas for the star
wars universe
what are their toilets look like last
but not least
the rogue 808 jt
jt my god oh i
i would take you away oh to a galaxy
far far away show you the stars
jt because you've been one of our most
loyal patronage
since the dawn of time since before we
even had a patreon page
you have been pledged to our channel and
i
i just really appreciate you a lot
i what i did for christmas we got a
treat
we got a tree and then we got a train
track that took me two hours to assemble
it says ages three plus what a bunch of
[ __ ]
and what i did was i made little jt
models little jt models and i put it on
the train
he's a little he's a little trained
conductor you're my little train
conductor going around in a circle
around our tree
that's a little j tree is what i call
tree tree you're my christmas tree
you're you're my
tree you're the good luck charm you're
the spirit of the holidays jt
we're bringing love to everybody choo
choo coming around the bend who's that
jt with a coal bushel full of gifts and
love
you're so full of i want to lick you
oh yeah i want yeah lick you
just like touch you and fondle you and
stuff
poke ya two four i mean
is it no
no one is jt
the 808 who's gone rogue in my heart
improv
you